this really should be more about
ah
this should be more about your aim than
anything
hey you guys i'm eliza and these are my
favorite snacks
do it
so i've been eating sour patch kids my
whole life i'm a huge fan of the candy i
find them very soothing
it's one of the few things i found that
i junk food wise that i can eat and eat
and i never feel sick uh that might be a
problem i might be part sour patch kid
and i love them so much that
my adoring fans bring me sour patch kids
it's kind of like an offering
sour patch kids sometimes they're old
and if they sit in the bag for too long
the sugar will absorb into the actual
gummy so if ooh my mouth is watering
that's so gross
you've ever get a hot patch cuz it looks
like this it means it's not fresh
it's not gonna be as sour and satisfying
as one of these
always go fresh
a lot of my snacks revolve around like
what's at a venue i'm playing when i
walk into a venue my first question is
is there a concession stand do they have
popcorn i love popcorn i love popcorn so
much there's a way to eat popcorn my
husband makes fun of me
because i won't look at the popcorn and
i constantly have my hand in the bucket
and used to feel around for the the
perfect quantity and then you just
funnel it in
and you have to replace it in your mouth
before you've even swallowed that first
batch
well
your mouth it was like a continual corn
shoot
the perfect combination this is great
for the movies ask your parents what
movie theaters were it's the salty and
butteriness of the popcorn with the
sourness of this combined
you'll never stop eating it
it's so satisfying
and the only way to feel truly sated is
to keep eating
i don't like chocolate i know that that
makes me like a bad woman i'm gonna lose
my girl card i'm not a chocolate fan
dark chocolate too like i get it like
you're like it's not really candy
because it's dark oh my god cause it's
dark chocolate ugh i'd rather just not
have a treat but i was in australia and
a fan gave me this cadbury dairy milk
marvelous creation jelly popping candy
this is different than other chocolate
bars first of all because it's dairy
milk for americans it's closer to our
kind of chocolate we have very sweet
very milky chocolate and the rest of the
world is like what are you eating
[Music]
it's the jelly from the popping
on this chocolate is so sweet
they're so good if you're from australia
or if you're from the uk at all
you know about this
go you gotta be rapid fire quick
good and plenty i only know about good
and plenty because my mother loved good
and plenty most people
uh have a vehement disdain for black
licorice it looks like drugs which i
think is part of the fun and the trick
to eating these
is you gotta load up
now
you can't chew it
like you would tobacco
constantly pressing it
on the liquid
black licorice liquid the anise kind of
pools in your jowls
and then you
slurp it up what's another great way to
do them is you pour them out at the
bottom of your purse and because they
don't go bad you always have free purse
snacks leave treats for yourselves treat
yourself right
okay all right
this is probably the the most special
one i'm gonna catch it go
okay
so when they asked me to do this show
and they asked like so many times they
were like whatever candy you pick
whatever snacks you pick we will source
them and i was like i'll give you
something to source
jojo
these are from
czech republic
they couldn't source them you guys
couldn't source them i had a bag of
these because i just did a tour in
europe and a fan gave these to me i
think when i was in hungary but this is
a check candy
and i was so blown away by how good
these were i instagramed about it and
other fans brought them this looks like
your average sour worms but they were
just better
it's just a deeper flavor because it's a
foreign candy
it's probably real fruit juice
and it's just
like the kids say it just hits different
if you're planning a trip to czech
republic pick you up
a bag of jojo
it's not plural and it's not possessive
jojo okay up next we have halva first of
all it's made of sesame seeds
a lot of cultures lay claim to this
we'll call it a northern mediterranean
middle eastern snack i would call it
more middle eastern israelis jews lay
claim to this the rest of the middle
east lays claim to this so we'll leave
it at that it's something that all
cultures can come together on because it
is tasty this was something growing up
jewish that my mom ate when she was
little and they have it at a lot of like
jewish delis so she gave it to me and
i've always loved it they gave me a
spoon to eat with it because it does
look like yogurt i you can use a spoon
you can use a fork sometimes it's cut up
in little pieces you just eat them and
now it's kind of been commercialized
the best part about holla i think is the
texture it's like sandy some people i'm
a texture person i can't well i can it's
so satisfying
[Music]
well those are my snacks those are the
snacks that fuel me and those are the
snacks of my life thank you for watching
this was
easily the easiest 50 grand i've ever
made and come see me on tour eliza.com
tour i'm definitely playing a city near
you and i will definitely be snacking
backstage
[Music]
you